hello reject nation i am greg alba with
me today is charmita Bhattacharya hello
guys hello guys hello
wellsure Mita you might have seen her
from the chebika a channel where she
gets jabbed by the co a that doesn't
even make sense
it sounds sexual doesn't it yeah I'm
sorry
speaking of not sounding sexual FRC Lin
kid venture friends she's the one who
won the 100 we need to figure I was
going to sing tonight obviously to be me
I'm Marie we're all here
[Music]
grievers yeah how she's talking guys you
shouldn't fight you need to work
together like some of the famous duo's
like war Laurel and Hardy Hall & Oates
Simon and lb appreciate you know what
guys I think everyone here is wanting us
all the same so I was thinking that we
could sing a song it's by Paul McCartney
and John Lennon it's called a little
with a little help from my friends
that's funny bunny singing a song
written by two Beatles oh great
so guy but part of my singing Darcy you
just stand there with her mouth closed
like you always do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well how is she
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
magic I don't understand oh my god is
crazy
[Music]
maile impressive mightily impressive man
[Applause]
hey hi you're still pretty you know when
she first started I was like okay that's
cute yeah she's a little girl doing her
jokes I'm like it's so impressive I will
follow this show like when it's Airy
even though the title says sing so that
I wasn't expecting like whoa this is I
didn't even read that
this is really good singing for someone
who's not opening their mouth and
singers reliable she's not in yet like
to enunciate and Ollie changer register
I'm going back and forth between the two
voices and having that song so flow you
know like that was those talked about
living up to the pressure being in front
of 16 million people man mightily
impressive oh my god she's gonna be a
superstar and then she's gonna ruin her
life ten years from now when she gives
in to the fame and the alcohol and the
drugs
be careful Darcy Lin be careful I don't
know how how to do like a regular
ventriloquist I should try I'm like
weirdly tapping your back every time
series America's Got Talent videos I'm
just like I've done nothing I like my
life ya know with my life she's like a
five year old kid and she threw away
more talented than anything I've ever
accomplished this was a good idea I'm
glad to be watch this you know if I was
a wiser man I would be like well you
know I'll use this inspiration to
motivate myself to work harder
and hone in on my skills but I'd rather
just be cynical and say God is unfair
and he blessed this white girl with
gifts as an ethnic man in America and an
ethnic woman we are cursed to be doomed
by the whites I like to make videos
about other things Garcia and Mythili
impressive I think she's the one who
actually did win the competition and if
she did or even in the top three
whatever rightfully so she deserves it
I'm glad you're here show me that to
experience this yeah me too
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell follow shower meetha
bhattacharyya me that's me yeah not not
me charmita she's an actress model
singer and silly goose yeah over on
Instagram I follow her I'd like every
other photo they are good photos with a
lot of life and have you promote
someone's Instagram follow them right I
don't know why am I trying to do more
you should be like you should go there
and see what I see why you call yourself
a silly goose huh isn't that adorable